let me ask you girls a question the
reason she decided not to go is because
this is obviously not a regular
occurrence right so he had a reason and
she trusts his judgment let me give you
girls a scenario let's imagine I'm with
a chick whatever she has a concert I
said I don't want to go and she she
replies like you why can't I go and I
say got a bad feeling don't go ah now
what now so which would you think the
woman should just go I don't give a [ __ ]
about this stupid feeling and bounce
the reason
there's no reason
this is the thing it doesn't make sense
listen my sister this is the key when
you say I don't know I just call bad
feelings let me tell you how that is get
translated into my head he cares about
me and he's actually thinking about
something that potentially could be
happening that I'm not aware of I love
him for thinking outside the box but you
reassured me you've shown me respect for
being able to open my own decisions and
that's all it takes no that's all but no
but